BRETT MORGAN: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2019,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to all of them.
So if you didn't get to see
Build Mobile Apps with Flutter
and Google Maps, then stay
tuned because here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
As a developer
relations engineer,
I often hear from
developers that they
need to develop mobile
experience for their customers
faster, and they want their
app to be a joy to use.
Flutter allows developers
to write once and deploy
everywhere, saving time
and money by developing
for both Android and iOS using
one development team and one
code base.
Developers usually love coding
with Flutter as we empower them
with stateful hot
reload, which gets
their changes onto their
device just by hitting Save
in their editors, which is
exactly what our talk at Cloud
Next was all about.
Here is a quick
montage of the app
I built live on stage
in San Francisco,
mapping out the ice cream stores
around the conference center.
We started, as always,
with hello world.
Then we connect
Google Cloud Firestore
to get a list of
ice cream stores.
Next, we exposed a list of these
stores using List View Builder
and added Google Map to
enable us to visualize
where the stores are.
We then utilized Google
Maps web services
to retrieve photos
for the stores.
And as one final flourish,
we built a carousel
to enable users to swipe through
the list of stores easily.
To watch the full talk, check
out the link in the description
below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]